[Music]
justin joins us in glendale arizona
justin welcome to the ramsay show
thanks how are you today doing great how
can i help
yeah i got a kind of what would you do
situation oh these are fun me and my uh
right me and my wife are renting we're
renting a house from her grandfather he
decided to sell it to us for around 200
000 and then appraise for 440 right now
wow um
he's actually given us 15 in cash on top
to just kind of help out his
granddaughter he was going to give her
the house free and clear but he decided
he couldn't really do that so this is
what he's doing for us okay
we we don't have any car loans or any
debt i have maybe
twelve hundred dollars on some credit
cards that was honestly getting ready to
pay off
um
should i pull out some of this equity to
fix the house up the house is in good
condition but there are some things that
are wrong with it i'd like to get done
um and then also i you know me and my
wife have only been married for a couple
of years and i don't have
really any real retirement or savings
going right now so do you have an
emergency fund
i have five thousand
you got five thousand and you have 1200
on credit cards
yep dude pay that credit card off today
is that the only debt in your life
that's about it right now what's about
it is there more here
what's the full story no there's no no
that's it i had one i have one credit
card i'm an avid hunter so i have one
credit card i was using to put stuff on
to get the points
we'll let that go about six months
revolving and rotating and then i end up
paying it off when my hunting season's
over
well look at that here's what i'm gonna
tell you to do go listen to our credit
card rewards episode of the fine print
hopefully that'll change your mind on
this whole rewards thing it's a scam man
and uh i don't want you falling for it
anymore you guys have a bright future
you've got an incredible opportunity
here but what you're asking me is should
we use a heloc to get this house fixed
up correct correct
the answer to that is a resounding no
uh the heloc is gonna put your home at
risk
uh it's probably gonna have a variable
interest rate and it's gonna set you
guys back
in the long run and so what i would do
is cash flow these repairs as you can uh
can you get into this
you're you're in the house right now
we are renting
uh it's in escrow right now it should
close on the 30th okay and you can
afford this mortgage
absolutely all right on in are you
getting a 15-year fixed
oh it's 30 here oh boy is it too late to
switch
yeah oh boy okay well glad i caught you
at least in this moment to stop you from
from doing the heloc what we recommend
is 25 of your take-home pay on a 15-year
fix that's what i want the mortgage to
be uh because i don't want you to be
house poor but on the heloc side
absolutely do not do don't mess with a
heloc don't do that okay
it's gonna be a nightmare and when you
go through that line of credit it's to
come
that balance is going to come due in
full and the bank can take your home and
so this is putting you in a real risky
financial position
that i don't want you guys in as you uh
you know you're in this the early stages
of this marriage i want as little
anxiety as possible so avoid the heloc
cash flow the repairs as you can make
them you said it's livable there's
nothing on fire here cash flow these
repairs as quickly as you can you've got
some money but i need you to build that
fully funded emergency fund as soon as
you pay off those credit cards
and you can do that all within a few
months and then start to cash flow these
repairs soon after that
that's what i figured i just wanted to
get in i appreciate you taking my call
and kind of letting you bounce some
ideas off yeah absolutely justin happy
to help